pater réussira son fjord tout ce bordel
de merde qu'elle a créé derrière elle et
surtout ses amis vous qu'il s'en sortir
va t elle s'en sortir l'hélico va-t-il
s'en sortir bref tout le monde va-t-il
s'en sortait rebelles comme merde tu
peux plus te voir ja demandent s'excuser
un centre aujourd'hui pour l'épisode
numéro 8 sur tomb raider alors ouais ça
fait longtemps que je n'ai pas sortir je
m'excuse d'ailleurs c'est juste que
j'avais une petite baisse de motivation
quant à cette série parce que je
trouvais le commander toute attente
retombée d'avoir ça d'accord je crois
que c'est ok parce que oui je trouvais
toujours un petit peu répétitif et en
fait j'ai juste découvert un petit peu
league of legend et j'y jouais plus
souvent qu'avant avec avec mes potes sur
skype enfin sur le ts pardon donc
forcément j'avais un petit peu moins de
temps pour faire ses thèmes raiders là
alors vous inquiétez pas on va remédier
à ça tout de suite
on va mettre des flèches en feu voilà
aulas [ __ ] ils font trop mal alors
est-ce que y'a pas moyen de les défoncer
voilà reparti à homme
or un jeune homme il est tombé raide hop
et le petit dernier la aux jeunes et aux
complémentaires annoncées n'ont pas dit
non aux complémentaires aujourd'hui
tentez votre chance à cette fois c'est
bon alors là doit bouger appartement
petit truc de matériaux ou quoi des
munitions s'en fout et des oies ou non
mais des fois il fait ça plus partagés
c'est un gars me casse il m'a défoncé
mon cul oui bon allez on va essayer de
se concentrer un petit peu et c'est
parti j'ai bien joué alors c'est quoi
elles n'ont à séglien voix c'est d'être
efficace tout à l'heure mais qd tu as
pris feu tu es revit tutu arbitres tuer
tuer suisses ubcs à mende au revoir bon
c'est quoi avant d'aller chercher les
autres pour être élu
oui j'ai dit
puis j'ai dit hop y avait une grenade
dans mon dos alors comment va finalement
se sortir de ce truc e ou casse toi mais
laquelle suicidaire suis là bas aux
manettes mais tu coûtes pur les wave tm
et est balèze la mecque alors on va
ramasser tout ça c'est bon et j'ai pris
cher là non non non non non non non on
va pas remonter un soir de questions qui
m'attirait d'au-dessus bande de rats
m'en tiens bon adaptateur bas on
ajustait les attendent ici en fait en
fin de compte un gain de temps est
devenu plus il joue commentaire
merde ça va tu ailles fait super mal des
fois les ennemis c'est abusé bon c'est
ça tape est allé on met toi
bon alors ce que je vous disais un
pourquoi j'avais arrêté un petit peu les
tomb raider c'est justement pour ça
c'est un petit peu souvent la même chose
dans le sens sur des batailles mais
alors le jeu est très très prenant que
ce soit au niveau de l'histoire comme au
tout début du gameplay mais je trouve
que voilà csn un petit peu répétitives
de vagues d'ennemis qu'on doive but et
ça va bien quoi c'est pas naturel quoi
sert le toit à moi car ma mère dira t on
voir
bon alors comment on fait
ok waouh non ah bon
ça va un moment casse toi
voilà ça mais bon [ __ ] sérieux quoi
hop tu veux plus quelques matériaux
passage jeune homme sera mignon très
bien à l'est continueront encore à la ba
ouai bon bah écoutez on va ramasser vite
fait en plein milieu du champ de
bataille on s'en bat les steaks brisé
ouf
regardez combien ils sont quoi un moment
ça va
il a bien visé sur un énorme ivrogne
j'ai un bon usage et depuis quelques
années derrière les autres on est ce
qu'on peut pas passer par là non ça
pétait non c'est bon vers la bataille
promet de la tête remettre au crâne tout
chaud voilà j'aime quand même chose et
toi repens toi ça c'est bon runje
je pense que c'est bon non il reste un
petit dernier avant hop traître
ok alors j'ai littéralement une grosse
flemme d'aller chercher les matériaux
sur chaque ennemi hauteur est de trouver
comment elle allait alors on va faire la
technique bas les steaks
[ __ ] ce qui m'énerve
ok voilà c'est long on a réussi où ça
s'est fait ou alors là est-ce que c'est
reparti non alors cette fois je vais la
dra 10 et jean petit et non
alors
eux qu'est la touche tu t'es savoir
comment faire un pop up
alors donc on va tirer dans le bidon je
suppose
ça ça servait à rien d'ailleurs assez là
bas ok mais là bas ou
pour on y est 3 québec est à l'ego
maman
tac
hu
bâtard non mais ils vont nourrir mais
des fois ils prennent pause puis j'aime
les gens ouais c'était chaud tout ça
alors on va en profiter pour prendre
cette fois voilà les vraies
les vrais jeune homme alors est-ce qu'on
peut pas tuer entre les
moi ça me saoule et lui
tiens feu d'artifice vautorte web on a
la rage je pense que n'importe qui
serait mort dans ton cas un bon mois de
forte n'abuse pas fâché rome
je te suis et ça ne monte pas dans
l'hélicoptère
fais moi confiance d'accord je t'en prie
je fais moi confiance
allez ça ne monte pas dans l'écho ben
oui puisqu'elle a été lu la reine tout
et du coup bas chaque chose qui veut
aller celui qui veut partir se prendre
tempête
donc certes c'est pas génial
alors on a donc des balles je suppose
qu'il faut passer par là on y va hop
madame allez bon seigneur me brûle
attendez du coup je galère un petit peu
non ça sera pas là ça peut être que là
alors non non peut-être à droite
voilà à partir de là à mon avis pour
faire tout tour by and bar lara a alors
encore un truc à la con qu'on va
résoudre jusqu'à influencer sur ta là
pourquoi ils nous aident pas je
comprends pas si on monte la voix là bas
non mais pourquoi tu veux pas monter
qu'est ce que c'est que ces gens là vont
tomber amoureux d'elle et si je fais x
qu'elle s'accroche noms marchent pas bon
alors on va peut-être dire est qu'elle
est là non plus bon c'est super de
retrouver non mais son sérieux là les
gens
voilà c'était bien là bon je me disais
défaut en fait elle s'accroche pas tout
seul donc c'est un peu galère à faire
alors vas-y les câlins ce bruit me fais
pas l'eau dans le bruit de la corde
sérieux t'a fait c'est super mal aux
dents un peu comme une craie sur un
tableau qui s'était alors
voilà
ouais bah bazire n'a plus qu'à foncer
un homme
alors voilà droite
nickel oh là là là là on serait bien
mort brûlé tout je pense à tous ceux qui
arrivent deux seraient morts mais
carbonisé du cul du terreau allemagne je
veux empêcher de monter dans cet
hélicoptère au nom ne dit pas que
et puis c'est tout
mais nous sommes
y at il d'autres incroyants
oh la vache
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
à
ah ouais non mais là où merde tiens y
boom
batta
oh là là là lâche encore je vous parie
qu'on va trouver dans un trou ouah ouah
oh la vache
non
attendez mais en fait c'est trop
dangereux
à la sq oh là là là oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] je stresse pas prêtes à
iasi
mais par où ils passent là à des
conseils mal comme la planète te
connaissais pas allez allez allez allez
voilà la wii le piolet vous allez monte
monte monte monte monte vas-y monte
badie lara montre-nous tennant ça monte
monte monte monte monte ouais
c'est quoi ce bordel les gens c'est la
guerre
[ __ ] annonce l'ajout chien pas aimer
est tombé tard c'est quand même
vachement beau mais non j'ai souhaité
drogue
je suis trop blasé pourquoi tant de
temps à perdre j'étais en train de boire
mon thé comme un vieux portable et je
aller fausses bases hilare à aller au
parc antoine way x x c'est bon voilà on
a eu trop 6,6 et là on fait quoi
c'est bon on l'a eu ouais bah juste
avant l'été sur la caisse
oh la vache je pense qu'il faut sauter
la fenêtre son truc
voici voilà
mais je crois que la race est quand même
la fille la plus chanceuse de
franchement la rage ou au loto et direct
tu as ta place j'aurais joué depuis
longtemps sans d'ailleurs battu ce que
je veux mais à l'école balayette
s'enfuit la fille
lara tu part en cacahuète quand tu veux
je te mets non mais mais à droite bordel
voilà bagdad
hop je suis en position de chip saute le
plus aux békés qui est plein de pop et x
voilà autant pour moi
alors on est en train de monter une tour
complètement en crue qui va s'effondrer
d'un moment à l'autre
mais l'art n'est pas peur elle est quand
même incroyable sa terrasse [ __ ]
n'empêche pas que l'écho va se crasher
oh
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta voix
ma
et voilà
on se bat
aggravé avec 7 temple wat
martyrs
baj
pause mais qd entendu
tu vois des lits pas question avec ce
temps on ne peut pas les abandonner
désolé je vais pas sans risque et papon
on va tâcher tu
[ __ ]
vraiment un recap
cette manière
il
baj
commencez partir en cacahuète total j'en
reviens pas oh la vache
oh merde c'est le deuxième truc qui veut
aller chercher qui s'écrasera
il allie la famille zola il n'a pas su
en salle au chalet la vache
ça explose
[ __ ] et voilà
non
non pas 30 ans de tutelle nous a sauvés
tellement de fois il était tellement
gentil
j'y arriverai jamais sans toi
ras
je suis dégoûté pardon je suis dégoûté
sérieux
oh non
violaine croft
oh non mais non mais non mais non mais
non non mais là c'est trop bas dans
franchement pour le coup c'est pas cool
quoi c'est vraiment pas cool bon qu'est
ce qu'on va faire du coup pas cool du
tout ça non non on repassera
bah si tu n'as rien à l'art à si elle
n'a rien tout ce qui compte c'est la
race et ça tu as oublié que c'est à
cause d'elle qu'on est là un vieil
rageuse tu viens juste rien je sais
j'aurais pas dû dire ça on m'attaque s
remballe ta caisse ma faim j'essaie de
m'en coûte 7 de faire sans lui
on va lui trouver un endroit sûr et le
préparer dignement
est mort en guerrier il faut lui rendre
hommage j'ai un rhume lui jeta toile et
tous à coup sa grosseur
puisque jean ruby centre ce cadre
admet groban à gros gros bad
pas cool du tout
cette vieille vedette sur la plage
je devrais pouvoir la réparer
on peut essayer
ça ne sert à rien jamais nous partirons
de sept îles allez lara il faut pas dire
ça moi mais c'est vrai quoi de force à
mettre au point un plan tu vois vous ne
comprenez donc par aucun de vous quelque
chose nous empêche de partir quelque
chose
laraque devrait dormir écoute je suis le
premier à reconnaître que j'aime bien
les trucs bizarres mais cet endroit bat
tous les records
je ne veux pas mourir ici je répare ce
bateau et on s'en va
marc vazy jerome kaino et il est
spécifié tutoie ne dit pas le contraire
en couchage sais c'est qu'il n'ya rien
en hausse en gros vous choisissez entre
élus champagne au changement est une
tâche va ton instinct mais tu as tort
crois en toi
on a besoin de toi jaune a raison je ne
peux pas laisser j'ai besoin de temps
c'est à nous trouver
reviens quand tu sera prête
tu ira nulle part sans toi
l'insa sur toi
il est énorme le flingue
la taille et sa queue de cheval
cros remarques inutiles merci luca ross
qu'est ce que je vais faire
tu as beaucoup d'instinct lara il faut
que tu crois en toi
personne ne pas les tempêtes
elles doivent être liés au pouvoir de la
reine solaire ce qui nous empêche de
partir la chambre des rituels du
monastère si c'est ce que les gardes
protège alors c'est là qu'on découvrira
comment arrêter les tempêtes et une
entrée secrète par la rivière
le bateau on va s'en servir pour
remonter la rivière jusqu'à la chambre
des rituels
j'aime bien sonné
maintenant savoir
la casse
voilà un vieux truc je sur est obligée
là bas il ya un tombeau où des des trucs
c'est beau bon on va aller droite au
[ __ ] les gens tuent pas vraiment envie
de diva gay appareil un truc qui brille
regardez qu'est ce que c'est que ça
un géo cache très bien non je préfère
qu'on fonce vers l'objectif plutôt qu'on
qu'on fasse plein de choses à côté de
façon les matches comme jeudi en fin d
une vidéo spéciale bourse aoc
[ __ ]
parti trop de cassel
bon asie on vend tué 1
- 1
reste à faire discret c'est ça
fages comment s'accroupit je me suis en
paix merde
là
qu'est - 2 excusez moi les gens super
présenterait mais j'ai vraiment pas
envie qu'on se fasse opérer parce qu'on
va faire torcher quoi
salah ça va on gère pas trop mal mais
continuer là-bas il est un peu loin
quand même pas le tenter
des deux côtés on sait qu on va liquider
l'autre côté avant de défoncer l'autre
côté allez on y va on y va on y va
l'arago gogo c'est de faire quelque
chose il ya des flashes charges
s'élèvent s'inquiète pas je les ai vus
mais on a toutes nos flèches est juste
là je crois
soit
ok
on est encore pas mal à regarder non la
bac qui arrive en face
je n'aime pas lui me fait peur
alors on est fin prêt
alors non
alors qu'on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
justin
ok 2 encore là bas
trois là bas
4 ok c'est bon les a tous eu beau rien à
ton beau secret d'accord mais c'est pas
trop le moment j'ai envie de dire je
crois qu'on les a tous eu la whey ça m'a
l'air op quoique le tombeau juste là bon
allez on va le faire
ça se trouve il est bien il est mignon
on va encore devoir résoudre une énigme
à la cour comme ça on va se faire ça
vite fait à les fons bon nous revoilà la
sortie du tombeau j'ai pas trouvé
comment faire c'est assez dur et en fait
je suis tellement pressée d'avancer sur
l'histoire de de découvrir en fait
qu'est ce qui va se passer comment s'est
elle va remonter dans la chambre les
rituels et qu'est ce qui va se passer et
ensuite peut-être que oui on fera des
tombeaux et c'est qu'on n'a pas vraiment
pu faire
alors attendez déjà là dedans doit y
avoir un truc alors [ __ ]
ok donc la planque c'est là bas bon bah
ça tombe bien c'est là bas qu'on doit
l'être manière c'est un truc c'est qu'il
y en a un là un en bas et plein là ou
quoi
ou alors vous savez quoi [ __ ] mais
sale hongrois par host merde
on est mort alors là je suis désolé les
gens je pense à one on me away non mais
c'est chaud au lavage alors faut faire
tout un côté à gauche puis tout à côté à
droite
ah non mais ils sont hallucinants les
mecs un nom mais ils sont sérieux non
mais c'est chaud on va faire l'autre
côté
là qu'est donc l'erm a déjà 2 0 on va se
faire lui je pense
non
oh [ __ ] il m'a vu
on l'a eu
ah c'était une bonne planque l'eau c'est
une bonne idée
ok alors on s'est fait repérer on est
mort on va tenter de faire quelque chose
quand même
ok bravo aux bâtards dans la touche et
clou de cette distance
ok c'est bon on l'a eue alors [ __ ] la
bâche super dur cette mission taillée un
chien qui arrive à faire reculer
j'ai un domaine pardon on peut passer
par des médias je suis [ __ ] on est
tellement dans la merde allez savoir si
un mec du daf libye sont ok oh la vache
j'avais à dire chipper nid d'amour pour
la gauche moi je me suis fais tu pour r
j'aimerais pas mourir la [ __ ] on a
quand même fait pas mal d'ennemis un de
plus alors j'ai vraiment la flemme de
faire exprès d'aller sur les aînés pour
ramasser sans dec à un petit passage
secret qui va peut-être nous mener à
quelque chose de sympa non bon on a
juste fait de l'accueil est ce qu'on
peut pas monter way un parfait ça en
fait ne servent à rien je crois qu'on a
tué tous ceux de la forêt
alors attendez pas ce qu'on peut pas
mettre une grosse grenade là bas
ol&t basique celle là wahaha
moi
j'aime pas les chiens pour ne pas tard
ils sont drôles et chiens tomb raider
ils craignent les acnés
ça va être vraiment chaud les premiers
rien
notamment
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on
est tellement en mode swing et bien on
va attendre du succès avec quoi
[ __ ] voilà là là là depuis 10 ans n'a
plus de vie oui on l'a fait on c'est un
trio né voit lavage qu'est ce que
c'était chaud moi ya une porte là bas
j'aimerais bien la casse est juste parce
que là dedans
aller au bout alors y'a quoi là dans dix
mois qu'il ya des bals des choses c'est
pas à yes j'ai rarement là dedans et
trucs sympathiques
ouais pas mal de matériel c'est
sympathique ok pour moi c'est beau je
pense qu'on peut aller à dans le truc là
haut où sont allés nos amis en fait ils
nous ont mis un plan c c'est dégueulasse
qui vous allez on y va
hop nous y voilà
il y aura là dedans je me le demande hop
pétage de portes et puis voilà alors
voile et des walis une échelle déjà on
va dire qu'aller voir ce que la dot
et donc ça a changé quoi ça beyou
comme ceux dans la forêt
said de les dresser
ouais mais c'est comme ça ça pousse le
truc ça fait quoi ok bon bah de façon
vous savez quoi les gens si vous voyez
cette vidéo actuellement c'est que je me
suis arrêté là
sinon le plot de rémy trop de temps
alors on se retrouve bientôt à cette
fois bientôt vraiment dense un nouvel
épisode vous inquiétez pas je ferai pas
le coup deux fois et puis voilà n'oublie
pas d'aimer la vidéo si tu es bien les
petits épisodes tomb raider et tu vois
là un tuyau tout le monde
pis
il
tu ferais jour du temps et je remonte à
en boucle attends je vais faire on va
voir la vue qui